bonjour à toutes et à tous bon à vis des
as 2 mois le gâteau on pourrait parlant
plusieurs langues parce que aujourd'hui
on est dans l'international et c'est ce
qu'on vient vous présenter ma conférence
va porter sur la fin des frontières
géographiques du goût alors comment j'ai
pu arriver à cette fin des frontières
géographiques du goût donc j'ai mis au
monde une nouvelle science d'harmonie de
sommellerie aromatiques moléculaire donc
en rien à voir que la cuisine
moléculaire mais qui tout dans l'univers
aromatiques des arômes ans le maudit
d'univers romatique des arômes les armes
sont beaucoup plus importants dans nos
vies au quotidien vous vous laver les
cheveux ce matin ça sent le kiwi où ça
sent le melon d'eau tout dépend du
shampoing que vous avez et puis vous
êtes encore dans les pionts ça sent le
brûlé vers les enfants sont levés ils
ont fait des taux celui sont brûlés
alors ne nous sert énormément mais nous
sert en mangeant une serre en buvant une
serre à plein de choses et c'est ce que
je vais expliquer comment je suis arrivé
à ce chemin long et comment
l'international me survit de pouvoir
avancer parce que c'est dans la
rencontre avec les autres qu'on grandit
qu'on avance et tout ça se fait toujours
avec les autres en 82 j'ai quitté
je pensais est architecte moi je pensais
même en allant des architectures parce
que mon grand frère était en
architecture donc se voit quand on est
jeune on sait pas quoi faire on suit lit
enfin donc je suis allé j'ai quitté moi
je suis allé travailler on était au mont
tremblant et là j'ai découvert le monde
de la restauration
c'était vraiment un choc extraordinaire
dans le bon sens du terme c'est donc de
découvrir rapidement que fallait pas que
j'aille m'enfermant quatre murs il
fallait que je sois avec les gens
fallait que je communique que je rentre
en communion que les gens et que les
gens soient à table il doit voir comment
les gens me du plaisir à manger à boire
à à partager à communiquer entre eux
leurs sensations que l'assiette et le
vin leurs données non pour moi c'est une
source incroyable de plaisir alors j'ai
lâché l'école j'ai lâché leur section
j'ai beau mais un peu et après je suis
revenu au mont tremblant 85 et 86 ch
joue vers un bistrot de bières importées
avec un ami et là ça a été la véritable
découverte du goût pourquoi parce qu'il
avait des gens qui venaient
d'international on est à tremblant
on s'était promis contact véritable même
181,2 des jocistes fm là
j'arrivais à petit avec mon peu de
connaissances puis je pensais que je
connais tu sais tout sur la bia et je
servais des bières belges des allemands
où j'avais des clients qui venaient ces
pays-là connaissait la bière 100 fois
comme moi donc qui m'ouvre l esprit
alors rapidement je me suis mis à
prendre des notes et je tenais acheter
des livres sur les marchés des magasins
et là j'ai découvert tout un monde de
géographie d'histoire de culture de
civilisation de chimie de dégustation de
goût tous ceux que j'ai pas appris à
l'école parce que je trouve sur bull a
alors mais là il y avait je m'ouvre est
sûre le monde grâce au monde qui venait
à moins donc en février 89 j'ai décidé
d'aller un peu plus loin puis d'aller
prendre un cours de dégustation à
montréal donc j'habitais les laurentides
à l'époque mais j'ai un cours de
dégustation privée dans un club privé et
là ça a été le deuxième choc 2-0 à
camano qui est des vins qui viennent de
partout sur la planète on a honte je
peux mettre des mots sur ce que je
ressens
les véritables maux que langage comment
musée quelqu'un qui apprend la musique
bon on peut connecter ensemble et je
vais peut-être pouvoir voyager à travers
le monde grâce à ça
pas longtemps après jour la presse
jacques benoix chroniqueront et carvin
et écrivez un article sur sur la
sommellerie
il y avait aussi à l'école hôtelière au
québec qui donne un cours de sommellerie
à l'époque j'avais peur que ça voulait
dire le mot sommellerie à cette époque
là et là je commence à lire là dessus le
jeu tu vois aucun charme le journal
j'annonce au monde alentour de moins à
mon associé c'est fini je m'en vais en
sommellerie
voilà alors je suis parti là et je me
suis trouvé un travail au restaurant
marie-philip assez souvent qui venait de
gagner le mérite de la gastronomie
meilleurs resteront québec de l'année
ces gens là étaient des visionnaires
littéralement c'est lé el bulli j'dirais
de l'époque
el bulli je vous en parlerai tantôt vous
allez comprendre s'ils me connaissaient
pas le restaurant el bulli
ces gens là étaient avant leur temps et
voyagez beaucoup encore une fois yeux
des clients qui venaient d'être angers
nantes toujours en contact les gens
l'ouverture sur le monde
le bagage de connaissances là que les
clients de transférer puis que moi je
des comptes est que je pouvais restituer
à ma façon
donc ça me permet d'avancer et en
sortant du court de sommellerie donc en
90 je me suis dit bon impossible
après 500 sort de cours de mime de venir
devant vous à la table du bon soir je
suis le sommelier
non non non ça marche pas alors je
partis en france on le tout vendu avec
mon épouse et on est parti en france
pour vivait en bourgogne pour apprendre
le langage uniront le métier et en plus
je me suis dit je vais faire les
concours de sommellerie comme ça je vais
avancer énormément donc ça va m'obliger
à apprendre
m'obliger à a continué à étudier alors
voyager étudier rencontrer les gens à la
ja je suis revenu au québec j'ai trouvé
dans 2 tab extraordinaire avec des caves
exceptionnel je parle pas des gens là je
parle de la cave à vin donc avec une
table exceptionnel où j'avais le nez
fourré dans la cuisine parce qu'on ne
peut pas être soumis dès son connaît pas
la cuisine aussi
donc j'ai étudié des cuisines du monde
entier voyage à travers le monde pour le
la cuisine autant le street food la la
la gastronomie de rue que pour les
restaurants top top notch troisième et
trois étoiles et tout ça et j'ai eu la
chance de gagner des concours de
sommellerie qui m'ont fait avancer mais
surtout en 92 je me suis dit dans ce
sens
un laboratoire il faut que je puisse
être encore plus que juste le moment
travaille au restaurant en communion
avec les gens et puis aussi leur
partager ma passion ma connaissance avec
les gens et je suis très digne depuis ce
moment-là quand on partage avec les gens
quand on parle notre pensée se forment
notre cerveau dans tout ce qu'on a
appris ce fort mais il nous permet
d'avancer
donc j'ai créé le club demain françois
chartier ou j'organisais des repas dans
les restaurants j'arrive avec des menus
que j'ai fait moi même et qu'on pour
finir avec les grands chefs de du québec
les normands la prise de ce monde pour
n'en nommer qu'un seul donc et puis
continuer à faire des concours qui m'ont
mené un peu partout en france à tokyo et
rencontrer des grands ce métier
extraordinaire encore là l'international
me nourrissais énormément jalbaud allait
faire un concours on rencontre est
meilleure ce midi de chaque pays qui
sont là on passe une semaine trois
quatre jours ensemble
alors on se fait des amis on se fait des
collègues mais où surtout c'est qu'on
boit du vin et ensemble un alors mais
dans l'acte de bois et à la communion la
communication c'est super important donc
et en 95 on le géo qui ça me prendre
autre chose j'ai comme je tombais sur le
livre d'hervé this donc hervé this on le
voit ici je suis allé le rencontrer
après kate un grand chercheur
scientifique physico-chimiste
s'intéresse à la gastronomie que feu
plusieurs ouvrages et aux arômes et guy
aux etats-unis aussi pour moi c'est 2-2
personnage clé dans l'univers de la
gastronomie mondiale donc qui ont étudié
de façon scientifique la gastronomie qui
permet d'aller plus loin de comprendre
les gestes empirique que tous les chefs
pose de tous les temps pourquoi on sort
un rôti de boeuf du fourneau qu'il faut
attendre dix minutes où s'est tenu
notamment de couper du sang qui coule
oui pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi alors et
les réponses de ça c'est intéressant
parce que quand on les lit c'est souvent
ça va nous jouer des urgences et nous ça
nous amène maillard donc on a besoin
d'aller voir des gens comme ça entre
comme moi j'ai eu besoin dans les bords
des gens comme ça pour arriver en 2002
et d'audible je vais prendre une année
sabbatique parce que là ça va trop vite
je trop occupés faut que je me mette en
danger
je prenne un peu de recul pour regarder
où je dois aller où je vais amener ma
séance pour ma science sans conscience à
l'époque où j'ai emmené ma connaissance
et ma créativité dans ça je t'ai
challenger parler hervé this de ce monde
et par les chefs qui servait 5e nsa
ailleurs complètement la démarche génère
le produit si on ne change pas la
démarche on va toujours produire la même
chose j'ai ouvert le journal le devoir
en 2002 que je tombais cette phrase là
pendant mon année ce dos à batik parce
que je continue à travailler quand même
un peu et j'ai dit ok c'est ça c'est ce
que jim hendry que ce fait il a changé
la démarche
aujourd'hui après un solo de guitare de
musique rock et pas influencer par jimi
hendrix géré à 95%
assurément le sont ils entendaient un
son mais il n'avait pas les
instrumentations pour le faire ça
sonnait la can incroyablement si la
poche alors est allé voir des
techniciens il a échangé communier
parler avec eux bang bang qu'ils ont
créé des nouveaux sons le fos
wouah distorsion banques pour pouvoir
aligner les notes y amener la musique
ailleurs qu'on aime ou pas il a changé
complètement l'histoire de la guitare
l'histoire du saut dans la musique rock
parce que il est allé voir des
scientifiques en guillemets donc c'est
ce que j'ai décidé de faire don pourquoi
parce que j'avais remarqué à l'école
hôtelière quand j'étudiais en 89 pour
passer les professeurs tapas bon
encontraise gens courant qui était mon
professeur sur le professeur
exceptionnel tous les livres de
gastronomie me disait fromage bleu
sauternes des huit le muscadet des
grands mariages classique antibombe
formidable on va aller en acheter
on va joindre l'utile à l'agréable
commence à goûter au ca marche pas tout
le temps
simon muscadet est très fruité piétons
minérale plus cher 18 hyper minérales
avec ça les huit écrase le but caennais
si le fromage le et upa puissant hyper
mature et charasse au turn avec sol
sautent en devient métalliques
j'ai comment je vais faire mon métier
moi là je vais arriver à atteindre puis
je dois expliquer aux gens que vous
venez prendre plateau de fromages bleus
je vais vous servir un sauternes vous
allez voir c'est exceptionnel au son de
sa voix est exceptionnel
donc je me suis aperçu rapidement que
tout le patrimoine gastronomique
mondiale était fondée sur dans la
communication dans le travail sur le
sucré le salé l'acide et l'amer quatre
choses on peut rajouter lomami mais je
rentrais pas là dedans ou en avoir pour
deux heures alors mettons 5 chose sur
lequel on a fondé la cuisine ici vous
avez 0 point 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 1 % des
molécules aromatiques que dans notre
environnement tout les geôles orange que
vous plais le shampoing aux kiwis au
melon d'eau que je parlais tantôt
lettons se brûler l'arôme de bananes
dans le beaujolais nouveau le cilss a
beaucoup plus d'impact
des milliers des dizaines de milliers
d'armes sont dans tout ce qu'on mange
régulièrement beaucoup plus sympa que la
city le salé le sucré lama donc j'avais
déjà remarqué ça donc j'ai eu le bonheur
de mettre le doigt sur quelque chose
comme je me suis posé des questions que
personne n'avait jamais pensé ce qui
fait pas moins de personnes derrière ce
fait moins grands curieux
en combinant des ingrédients ou des
liquides dominé par des molécules
aromatiques de même famille un plus un
fait pas 2 1 + 1 fait trop c'est le
nouvel mathématiques du goût qui étaient
corroborées par des scientifiques avec
qui je travaille avec qui j'ai travaillé
avec cuche est allé voir donne un
exemple fenugrec fenugrec entrent dans
la composition du curry le vidéo du
début
1 donc le fenugrec est une molécule qui
domine 9 432 mais en sortir c'est de
s'auto l'on a besoin de retenir ça mais
l'auto long on trouve ça aussi dans le
sirop d'érable dans le 8 la coache que
vous avez eu le maïs avec la pourriture
du début lac la musique mexicaine dans
lé vin de xérès et 6 1 ci-dessus et
honte au sol en plein champ ce qui
permet de tracer des frontières
géographiques de faire des plats
traditionnels à base de curry mais avec
du sirop d'érable et du bit la coach est
en place
ça vous coûte exactement la même chose
de faire débat alors on a fait
l'expérience avec des chefs et c'est
tout à fait renversant donc on retrouve
ça dans un paquet de type de vin des
vieux sauter des sacs et nego rider des
château-chalon des robes brodées bière
brune donc alors je partis avec cette
idée là je suis allé
dr béliveau en 2004 je dis docteur voilà
mon idée je veux comprendre qu'est-ce
que dans le fenugrec et qu'est-ce que
dans le dans le dans le vin jaune du
jura s'est enfin c'était ça ma première
recherche total que je traînais depuis
des années sans savoir pourquoi et j'ai
dit si on comprend les molécules que
daria ça peut-être qu'on va pouvoir
expliquer de façon scientifique
l'harmonie des mets et des vins et si on
capable d'expliquer ça peut-être qu'ils
vont des découvertes à faire moi c'est
ça qui m'intéresse c'est d'expliquer
mais d'aller ailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs celle internationale
alors là il me dit si vous ne faites pas
je vais le faire ouais donc j'avais ma
réponse je vais aller voir pascal
chatonnet qui est un ami aussi deux
thèses de doctorat sur les packs
aromatique des vins l'élevage en
barriques et tout ça c'est le bordelais
c'est un grand tonneau look de ce monde
ils me disent exactement la même réponse
que dr béliveau donc le principe d'
harmonie sur madre moléculaire et tanner
suite à ces rencontres là que je sais
pas la cuisine moléculaire c'est le
molécule c'est pour le mot molécules
aromatiques rien à voir que la cuisine
moléculaire et là je suis parti en 2002
2003 2004 à voyager aller voir surtout
des cuisiniers et des scientifiques
si je suis allé à ses nerfs l eurocorps
ils ont créé un plat à partir de jeudi
d'un dissipateur il dit si de la terre
humide qui cueille au matin gratte la
terre humide dans un endroit forêt qui
est propre à la mc2 la terre on l'a dit
si ça nous donne nos à saveur de terre
et ont fait une huître tu atterris
montagnat c'est extraordinaire alors oui
alors que challes gt challenge
énormément par ces gens là j'allais voir
des cuisiniers comme l'espagne sous clé
à barcelone qui travaillent dans le salé
avec le sucre et donc la ligne est très
fine aujourd'hui entre le salé le sucré
mais ça challenge au sommet dit cela il
ya de la moutarde la danse dessert la
dont vous voyez on rentre dans d'autres
univers complètement je suis allé voir
des producteurs de vin ici c'est alvaro
palacio grands producteurs de vins
d'espagne parce que ils voyagent à
travers le monde et rencontres toutes
ces chefs là donc il ya beaucoup échangé
dans la rencontre ça me nourrit
énormément chevalet dans les restaurants
aux états unis guen tâche ici fin plan
de pétanque avec des herbes tout sommet
en dessous c'est de l'eau chaude avec
l'inde hermes qui fait que ça vient les
arômes honte
et pendant que tu manges tu as
l'impression dangers de la camomille que
tonton petton qui parfumait la camo mais
il est passé en dessous c'est la route
qui monte à jiwa ok formidable on
travaille les arômes la travailler
beaucoup et que stéphane modat que vous
connaissez probablement chef maintenant
du château frontenac des restaurants
c'est mon grand complice on ne crée cinq
livres de recettes ensemble plus de 1500
ressortent donc ça m'a permis d'avancer
et en 2006 j'ai été approché par ferran
adria du restaurant el bulli en espagne
cinq fois meilleur restaurant au monde
qui a entendu parler qui avait un jeune
geek à sainte-adèle j'habite à
sainte-adèle époque qui travaillaient
sur les arômes dont je suis allé je les
rencontrer ces gens là je les ai
exactement ce fois le cheval et leur
expliquer que ce que je tenterai de vous
expliquer et puis ferrand n'a accroché
je suis allé chez alicia qui est un
grand laboratoire de recherche à
barcelone en gastronomie
je travaille avec des scientifiques là
bas et ce que je fais encore ça me
permet d'avancer faire un adria m'a
demandé de revenir et de venait
présenter mes travaux en 2006 à toute
son équipe de joyeux fous
à table comme ceux de tout expliquer
mais tout ce que j'avais fait comme
recherche à l'époque pour leur permettre
d'aller ailleurs
alors c'est quand même pour moi ça et
c'est un moment un moment d'une vie
incroyable il est en train de tourner un
documentaire à l'époque donc je suis
retrouvé dans un documentaire el bulli
cooking in progress
donc voyez c'est ça allait à
l'international c'est les rencontres
c'est les portes qui sauve c'est toutes
les possibilités qu'il apprend aussi
j'avais de quoi leur rapporter mais j'ai
appris énormément de ces gens là c'est
des gens c'est fou furieux
oui vous la cuisine des connaissances il
travailler ici le parmigiano reggiano
qu'est ce qui était fait qu'est-ce que
pas été fait qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
moi j'arrive avec mes graphiques je me
dis le parmigiano reggiano partagent les
arômes avec le café à lui formidable il
a créé un cristal de parmesan alors à au
café et là c'est le cristal comme ça
c'est sa magie vous mettez cette feuille
dans votre bouche tel fonds est sûre les
qui fuit et vous avez un goût tout en
misant café mais on est dans une
troisième dimension ça dure pendant 18
minutes en bouche c'est hallucinant je
veux donner faim et la même si vous
sortez de table donc j'ai publié le
livre papilles et molécules qui était la
première pierre à cet édifice en 2009
donc pas payées molécules et qui a eu un
succès depuis incroyable bon là eu des
décotes extraordinaire de plein de gens
mais au delà tout ça d'avoir que le
livre remporter des prix un peu partout
et que ça ouvre des énormément de portes
c'est des rencontres encore ici avec
harvest hindou un spectateur c'est
l'éditeur l'éditeur en chef depuis 35
ans il a parcouru toutes les grandes
tables du monde
il entend une entrevue que je donne à la
bbc jeunette dernier le prix du meilleur
livre de cuisine au monde jeudi à paris
il essaie dans sa petite voiture en
oregon il entend l'entrevue comment je
le sais pas mais entendent entrevue à la
radio il m'appelle il dit quand même san
francisco et hop comme cocoon dit mehdi
lot
tu viens de changer les paradigmes n'est
totalement tout ce que j'ai appris le
tout nous amène ailleurs
en seconde on se lance en france pour
savoir cuisiner avec papier ça y est
rencontre exceptionnelle formidable
talent et faire les courses ensemble
mais cuisiner et loyal échanges
encore une fois c'est pas juste moi
c'est l'autre c'est alors le livre a été
traduit en anglais bon robert parker été
interpellés le grand le grand gourou
divers mondial enchaîne les rencontres
et robert park un peu on a échangé puis
lui avec toute son expérience de 20 mhz
et de gastronomie insiste un gastronome
incroyable
donc on a eu des encore une fois décote
formidable j'ai travaillé avec les
écoles cégeps m'ont appelé pour donner
des éléphants des ateliers scientifiques
ils ont créé un concours de sommellerie
moléculaires basés sur mon livre ou
cégep lionel groulx dans le cours de
sciences avec martel amoureux le
professeur la même chose au collège
lasalle un cours de soi un cours de 75
euros basé sur mon livre il ya même les
bédouins qui livrent monkey les papilles
et molécules
merci alain était facile celle là mais
bon alors je vais avancer parce que le
temps file puis j'ai pris trop de temps
les recettes de papilles et molécules
avec stéphane modat bon il ya plein de
choses qui ont suivi papiers pour tous
sont les crimes et 500 recettes dont qui
nous a permis de vraiment avancé lé
journal les journaux les revues
scientifiques se sont intéressés à
papilles et molécules scientifique
report fait un exercice sur le corps
scientifique américaine qui ont conclu
aux mêmes résultats que moi je suis allé
donner des conférences à barcelone ce
qui me permit de travail et de
collaborer avec des grands chefs
el celler de can roca meilleur
restaurant au monde aussi comme el bulli
gaston à curieux au pire ou à l'insa de
rennes ce grand chef de paris l'homme de
l'harmonie mais veillent depuis très
longtemps de pouvoir rencontrer cet
homme là qu avec une connaissance
incroyable et de collaborer c'est jérôme
ferrer que me connaissait bien au québec
donc les gens et j'en passe bien sûr et
ça me permit de créer une nouvelle gamme
de vins inspiré de tout ce travail
aromatiques là de penser l'harmonie mais
vrai avant de faire le vin et j'ai lancé
cette gamme la l1 sow qu il ya deux ans
ils sont toujours disponibles donc et
d'aller me promener un peu partout dans
le monde pour fait pour faire des biens
aussi avec des amis goldenberg créé des
bières inspiré pour la table à partir
des arômes
et je vais finir avec une dernière chose
qui me viennent le grand réalisateur
québécois s'est intéressée à papilles et
molécules
il a créé un film ont été ensemble
pendant presque quatre ans inspiré de
papilles et molécules donc le fameux le
nez qui se promène un peu partout à
travers le monde en ce moment
je vais finir avec le teaser et je vous
dis un dernier mot juste après voilà
merci j'ai pris un peu plus de temps
bonne fin de journée bonne conférence
on y verrait vous il ya mille choses à
apprendre à bientôt